Speaker 1: Let's go next.
Why don't we go to Mike from Massachusetts?
Mike, welcome.
Speaker 4: It is my pleasure.
I have a couple quick questions.
I you want to get to as many people as possible,
but I'll try to make them quick.
So while there's obviously still some of the
races out there that still need to be called
the important ones.
Clearly, this was not the red wave that the
race was, you know, drooling about, you know,
to totally dominate Congress and, you know,
block everything for Joe Biden.
What do you think that I mean, what do you
think the Democratic establishment is going
to take away from this?
Because one thing that people have pointed
out is that the only Senate seat that so far
they've been able to flip was Fetterman, who
ran on a relatively progressive agenda.
Do you think they take anything away from
this to take it in 2024, or do they just continue
to keep the status quo because that's just
what they like to do?
Speaker 1: And fortunately or unfortunately,
depending on your perspective, I would say,
unfortunately, this was such a unique midterm.
And you're right, there's races where votes
are still being counted that I don't think
there is one big takeaway.
And the truth is, I've said for a long time,
different types of Democrats make sense in
different parts of the country.
Would it be great to be able to run progressives
in every district, every Senate race and every
governor's race and win?
Sure.
But that just simply doesn't work that way.
You know, up in Massachusetts, the governor's
race, Maura Healey, not like the uber progressive.
And when you understand, well, Massachusetts
has a history of more centrist Democrats and
Republican governors, you have to kind of
say, well, if we if we ran like a super progressive,
it might end up with another Republican governor
in Massachusetts.
I'm sure you understand that.
And so I honestly.
Speaker 4: I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I was going to say in this particular case
from Massachusetts, I mean, the Republican
Party went from a very moderate like Baker
and leaped all the way to deal a right wing
nut like Neil.
So.
Deal.
Yeah, I mean, deal.
Sorry.
Yeah.
So, I mean, I don't, I think it was always
a foregone conclusion.
Maura Healey And that's one of the bad, yes.
Speaker 1: No, it maybe it's not the best
example this particular year, but it is sort
of an example.
So I think the takeaway from it for Democrats
really needs to be different.
Different candidates in different races can
make sense, don't compromise on what are the
most important uniting values.
And I would say one thing about Fetterman,
you know, I don't there was this confusing
moment about fracking.
At the end of the day, Fetterman said he's
for fracking.
So it he sort of backed off of as progressive
a campaign as he had been running.
And I know that there was some confusion during
the debate about that, but he was like, no,
no, no, I'm for fracking.
I'm for fracking.
So did he really run as progressively as maybe
you're characterizing?
I don't know.
But listen, it's a great thing that Fetterman
won.
Speaker 4: That's fair.
And I agree with that.
One more if you'll allow me and I'll let you
move on.
This one's probably going to get a few eyeroll
some from listeners, but I, I've just been
really thinking about this and maybe the perspective
has changed since this election didn't go
as we thought it might.
But I mean, do you feel like as a country
we're approaching a position where.
You know, just based on the division that
we have, the irreconcilable differences.
I mean, do you think we're approaching a point
where we have to have a legitimate conversation
about doing do is it the best is it in everyone's
best interest to keep the country together?
I mean, do you think we're approaching a point
where we have to have a legitimate conversation
about breaking the country up into two or
more pieces?
Speaker 1: I don't.
And the reason why, honestly, is exactly as
you said, two or more.
There is a lack of contiguity in exactly how
you would do it, even if we agreed we've got
to do it.
And it makes sense, which I don't believe
anywhere near a plurality of people are at.
I actually don't know geographically that
there's any you would end up needing like
six countries.
And obviously that's not going to happen,
you know?
Speaker 4: Fair.
It's just hard to it's hard to imagine how
we keep moving forward in a positive direction.
Speaker 1: How do we live with these people?
I mean, it's an alternate reality, an alternate
set of moral values.
It's no bar is too low for any candidate no
matter what, as long as they're not a Democrat.
Herschel Walker being the perfect example.
It's crazy.
I share the desperation.
I just don't think chopping the country up
into two or more pieces is going to be a thing
in the next few years.
Speaker 4: I know, and I don't know if that
would be the best move, because that would
remove a serious roadblock for countries like
China and Russia.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
Never mind the chaos it would wreak domestically.
Speaker 4: Fair.
Fair is just it is hard to imagine how we
keep moving forward with such drastic differences.
I'm waiting.
Speaker 1: I'm with you.
Speaker 4: All right.
Thank you for your time.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thanks, Mike from Massachusetts.
Great to hear from you.